as you know this week we are celebrating
beauty both
inside and out and something i truly
cherish in my life
are all of my beautiful relationships
and i find that one of the best ways to
nourish those relationships
is with a handwritten card and so i
thought
i'd reach out to a few past guests
and i got to team up with hallmark
to make it happen
hallmark's real stories collection is
actually
about all of life's moments and it
doesn't have to be a holiday for you
to buy and send a card to someone this
is a 365
opportunity to show support
encouragement
and appreciation to someone you are just
getting to know
or have loved your whole life and
everyone in between
this is from the support collection and
i wrote it to
my friend justin and it says be as kind
to yourself
as you are to everyone else and i have
to say
he is someone who has saved lives that's
how good he is to everyone else
he is 18 year old justin gavin from
brooklyn new york
he saw a burning car on the street with
a mother
and her three children inside and
without hesitation he risked his own
life
to pull each one of them out of that
burning car
into safety we found out that you're a
fan of the brooklyn nets and they wanted
to say thank you too
so we have hooked you all up we're
getting you season passes
i wrote dearest justin i'm so excited
for your season tickets to the brooklyn
nets
have so much fun remember be as good to
you as your own everyone else
lots of love your friend drew i love it
thank you drew and i hope to see you
soon
and this card is from the appreciation
collection
and it was totally my favorite and i
thought
hmm who should i send this to
jonah jonah larson is a crochet prodigy
and a good friend
of mine he authored his first book at 11
and he helped create a new library in
the ethiopian village
in which he was born he's since become a
correspondent for the show
and does so much including book reviews
this card says i love you this much
and it's got the cutest little dinosaur
on these beautiful metallic hearts and
it just really spoke to me
so i sent it to my dear friend jonah
larson dearest jonah
it's true i love you so very much i
can't wait to continue our journey
together to do good
in this world you are my inspiration
and the best partner ever see you soon
your friend
drew thank you so much for this letter
drew made my day
but i wanted to thank you for being a
really wonderful crochet friend of mine
thank you so much drew this is from
their encouragement collection
and i thought hmm who should i send some
encouragement to
i know my friend haley who was on our
show with carrie underwood
and she has a very incredible program
where she sells bracelets for good
i told my mom i want to sell them and
raise money for one of the hospitals
because of our show it upped her game
and she went from like a few thousand
dollars to almost
50 000 so i wanted to encourage haley to
keep
going dearest haley you are doing such
important work and yet you are the
sweetest young lady
and you are truly showing the power of
what is possible
i am sending you lots of love and
encouragement
to keep you going your friend drew
you're very one
thank you so much for thinking of me i
love it
your friend haley
i can't handle the level of sweetness i
really can't and starting today
hallmark is giving away one
million cards to help you connect
with those that you care about go to
hallmark.com forward
slash share caring to request your free
three card pack while supplies last
and vfx because we want you to make the
people in your life feel special right
away
you are all getting 50
hallmarks
so break out those pens and pour your
heart out
[Music]
you